hey guys I'm Justine and I am a blogger
it's crazy to me that there's actually
people out there that have no idea what
vlogging is but if you're watching this
well I'm pretty confident that you know
what a blogger is and hopefully you do
and if you ever actually wanted to be a
vlogger cuz now youtube is giving you
the chance with a YouTube next launder
program all you guys have to do is
submit a video we keep it down trying to
log here okay guys out the day with
submit a video by April eighteenth to
youtube.com slash creators and you'll
get a chance to win five thousand
dollars with a video equipment ten
thousand dollars and a YouTube promotion
oh if that's not enough I will get to be
your YouTube mentor if healthy guys blog
are the particular tricks and hey you
even want me to be in your videos that's
cool too not only if you want we'll also
be doing google hangouts where we'll get
to do just that hang out so get your
videos in youtube com / creators and i
look forward to seeing your videos and
login with you I'm gonna go vlog and
dance
dude
dude how many of your friends think that
you're crazy do they think you're crazy
when you're blogging and filming
yourself because trust me they think I'm
crazy but seriously YouTube has pretty
much much finished in my life I've
turned making fun videos into an actual
career so I want to help you guys do the
same achieve your dreams and that would
oppose it's a motivational speech now go
make your videos by